elle est belle elle est célèbre et elle
est très riche kate moss est l'un des
top modèles les mieux payés au monde
mais la voilà tout de même purement et
simplement licencié par une grande
marque de vêtements
kate moss fume ce qui n'est pas interdit
par la loi mais on l'accuse aussi de
prendre de la cocaïne alors là rien ne
va plus ces photos volées et de mauvaise
qualité publiés dans la presse populaire
montre le mannequin préparant
apparemment quelques lignes de cocaïnes
insupportable pour le géant de
l'habillement h&m la marque renonce donc
à sa campagne de pub avec ce prestigieux
mannequin question d'image
un scandale qui tombe en plein milieu de
la semaine de la mode à londres
les défilés se succèdent et tous ces
professionnels dénoncent l'attitude de
la presse populaire britannique des
célébrités
moi je crois qu'elle ne devrait pas
s'intéresser à ce point à la vie privée
des gens
londres se bat depuis des années pour
être une capitale de la mode au même
titre que milan se parlent et styliste
britannique aimerait beaucoup que l'on
parle de leur travail plutôt que de la
vie privée de certains mannequins aussi
célèbre soit ils tous ses mannequins qui
défileront aujourd'hui à londres
soutiennent kate moss elle reste ici une
sorte d'icône intouchable la police
londonien indique comptant ce matin
qu'elle entend bien enquêté sur ces
allégations de consommation de cocaïne